it's a natural instinct in many species
to protect their young
and sometimes it's not just their own
babies but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
humans earliest stage
it is a scientific fact that human
babies are designed to emphasize their
own
adorable helplessness to make sure that
other older humans
take care of them a baby's cry is an
inherently distressing
sound and when we hear it some deep
primal part of us
feels the urge to comfort and care for
the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the scp foundation here
where there are bunnies that can eat
anything teddy bears that might steal
your organs to make duplicates of
themselves
and chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murderous
insects nothing is what it seems here
and even the most
innocent and cute creatures may be
hiding a deadly secret
scp-734 being no
exception today we're talking about the
baby
this anomaly proves that dangerous
things can come
in small packages but where others only
saw misery and death
the scp foundation saw a certain
potential our story begins in the
maternity ward of a hospital in the usa
where every medical professional's worst
nightmare was unfolding
an unknown but incredibly fast-acting
flesh-eating pathogens seemed to be
running rampant across the hospital's
population
it began when patients who weren't even
admitted for dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain
some nurses and doctors in the maternity
ward began to experience similar
symptoms
as well as one of the infants leading to
a massive quarantine
effort while the initial symptoms first
appeared to be limited to severe pain
and discomfort on isolated parts of the
skin
the condition of the afflicted soon
escalated their skin began to messily
flake off as the cells comprising it
lost physical cohesion
and died it was a kind of strange
anomalous rot
that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the integrity of the outer
layer of skin
and then cause further disintegration to
deeper parts of the body
once the skin had shut off the pathogen
would turn its attention to what was
lying beneath
against all odds the disease affected
organs
muscle tissue the vascular system and
even
bones nothing was spared the victims
bodies would completely break down
and they would be dead within a few
hours by the time the pathogen had
finished ravaging its victims
what was left didn't even look human
anymore not only patients
but doctors and nurses that had been
walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human
tissue sitting in what had previously
been their hospital beds
whatever this was it seemed like the
fastest progressing infection
in recorded history hospital staff and
administrators were terrified
this appeared to be an entirely new
disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all
no cure they were even more confused
when several black vans pulled up
outside the hospital
and mysterious men in hazmat suit
spilled out and began setting up a
quarantine zone around the entire
building
whoever these strange people were they
definitely weren't
the cdc little did the hospital
personnel know
that this was the group you'd never want
showing up and putting your location on
lockdown
it was the scp foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes
and the foundation operatives
immediately began conducting debriefing
interviews with witnesses
they soon determined from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and hospital
surveillance footage
that everyone infected with the
mysterious pathogen had all been in a
particular section of the maternity ward
earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found
another strange detail an infant had no
registered mother present in the
hospital the foundation would later
learn that this was likely because the
baby's mother was the first victim
of the deadly disease after eliminating
all other possible options
it seemed that the only anomalous
element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself
the baby was a caucasian male human
infant between seven
and eight months of age nothing appeared
outwardly anomalous about the child
but they could confirm that every single
victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the
child earlier that day
everyone who had been at the hospital
was given amnestic treatment
and the foundation constructed plausible
cover stories for the deaths that had
occurred that day
like so many others before it the child
was secured and spirited away to the
nearest applicable foundation
containment site
there was reclassified scp-734
and finally the real testing into what
precisely this infant was capable of
could begin physiologically scp-734
appeared mostly non-anomalous the infant
had above average intelligence and
physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or
abnormalities that would suggest a
divergence from typical human biology
despite a vast array of tests performed
by the foundation into essentially every
aspect of 734's biology
they couldn't find anything that hinted
at the origin of the mysterious pathogen
but through some trial and extremely
costly error
the foundation was able to learn more
about how exactly the pathogen worked
the only vector for transmission seemed
to be direct contact with the baby
itself
up to and including the fluids and
residues it leaves behind
those affected cannot transmit the
anomalous flaking effect to others
meaning the risk of an epidemic is
relievingly minimal
but of course accidents still happen as
was discovered when one agent misplaced
her sympathy for the baby and decided to
remove her mask while interacting with
him
her logic was that her masked face might
have caused the baby some kind of
distress
and as long as she was only coming into
contact with him via her
own gloved hands everything would be
fine
but some dust particles were floating in
the air at the time and scp-734
sneezed in her face the agent began
screaming in pain and recoiling from the
baby
but it was already too late her fate was
sealed
she was taken to the infirmary and given
sedatives so that she could hopefully
die in as little pain as possible
in roughly 72 percent of cases
amputation of the affected areas has
prevented the entire body from
succumbing to the anomalous effects of
scp-734 but this isn't exactly
feasible where the point of contact is
the victim's head
within hours the agent's flesh had
flaked off her face
leaving her looking like a red bloody
skull a few hours after that
she didn't have a head at all throughout
the disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent
the foundation took grisly photographs
these photographs are shown to anyone
preparing to work on the scp-730
research project to teach them a hard
lesson on the importance of adhering to
proper safety protocols
and these protocols about how to deal
with the baby are
incredibly tight given that even
incidental contact
is often a death sentence anyone
entering the baby's containment chamber
needs to wear contained atmosphere
hazmat suits
anyone who makes physical contact with
the baby even when suited
up is immediately removed from the area
and subject to several hours of
quarantine and observation even
inanimate objects that have been inside
the containment chamber need to be
thoroughly sterilized before being
removed
given that even anomalous children like
scp-734 have very delicate needs
a handler is always standing by in full
hazmat gear to take care of the baby
these handlers are rotated every hour to
maintain alertness and
safety these handlers feed and change
scp-734 regularly
and sometimes even provide toys that
have been approved by the o5 council
the foundation has gone to great lengths
to keep scp-734 alive and comfortable
because they believe that scp-734 could
be an important asset for them in the
future
or more specifically they see great
strategic value
in scp-734's blood as mentioned earlier
contact with any matter from scp-734
triggers its deadly anomalous
effects including bodily fluids like
blood
but unlike many toxic pathogens in this
case
there is no risk of the infection
getting out of control
since the infected do not become vectors
for transmission
because of this the blood of scp-734 can
act as a powerful weapon for both
terminating anomalies deemed unviable by
the o5 council
and assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival grooms
contact with the blood would completely
destroy the target's body
with no other anomalous effects and no
evidence of who exactly conducted the
hit
scp-734 has been fitted with an arterial
catheter
so that the foundation can collect large
quantities of blood from the anomalous
infant every single week for storage
and research but it isn't just the blood
that the foundation sees potential in
scp-734 himself has scored incredibly
well
on the esslinger loyalty index the test
the foundation uses to judge the loyalty
of potential applicants to the
foundation
cause as scp-734 matures
if these scores remain consistent he
will likely be trained to become a
foundation field agent in the future
an agent capable of killing someone with
a touch would
needless to say be an asset to certain
covert missions that the foundation
would probably prefer to keep off the
books
of course the scp foundation recruiting
certain compliant anomalies to perform
missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these
is scp-076 also known as
abel a supernatural eternally
resurrecting swordsman and perhaps one
of the finest warriors who ever lived
the foundation took note of this and
channeled his eternal thirst for battle
into working with his very own mobile
task force
he could assist in missions by taking
out his bloodlust on enemy groups of
interest and dangerous anomalies however
this ended
up working a little too well and led to
disaster
abel was so good at his job that he
burned through all of his allotted
missions at astonishing speed
left with nothing more to do abel got
antsy which led him to turning his
murderous
desires on his fellow team members and
then the foundation
as a whole it was an all-out massacre
before his colleagues were finally able
to kill him and return him to
containment
the failure of this initiative gave the
very idea of letting
anomalies work for the foundation in the
field a bad name
but since then things have changed
especially with the establishment of mtf
alpha 9
aka last hope a new mobile task force
formed entirely of anomalous individuals
and their handlers these consist of
somewhat more stable
anomalies such as abel's counterpart
scp-073
also known as kane kane cannot be harmed
with any harm befalling him simply being
mirrored back on his attacker
and his vast array of knowledge makes
him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of last hope is iris
also known as scp-105 much like kane
iris not only has anomalous powers that
make her immensely valuable from
missions in the field
she's also compliant and capable of
listening to reason
unlike kane her abilities include being
able to actively surveil and even
interact with photos of any location
especially when taken with her anomalous
camera someday
scp-734 could count himself among other
anomalous foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages
since after all he won't be a baby
forever
so if you ever find yourself on the
foundation's bad side
you have a good reason to be paranoid
you'll have no idea that one day
the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile
it won't be until later when you feel
that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize
you've been a dead man walking for hours
now check out scp-823 carnival of
horrors
and scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories
for more classic series scps from scp
explained